this man has won praise for transforming
Rwanda into one of the world's fastest
growing economies president Paul Kagame
has curb street level corruption
attracted foreign investment and reduced
the country's poverty levels so why are
his people so frightened of him
[Music]
Kagami came to power in 1994 when his
forces swept aside the government which
had orchestrated the genocide of more
than half a million people the majority
were Tutsis but many moderate Hutus were
also killed
sikozu reproduce at the period for food
or water any period the doulas spins are
all very beautiful what is near multiple
do you treat me to containing the best
Sol de firma : yes Elena the campus
President Kagame an ethnic Tutsi and
leader of the Rwandan Patriotic Front
has kept the peace at home even as he's
pursued wars against neighboring conquer
present kept things simple and focused I
think the biggest success that Kadam has
achieved since the mid nineties is the
the reduction in mass poverty which has
been quite exceptional by African
standards under Kagame 's leadership
this small landlocked country has
notched up growth rates of 8% a year
since 2000 a shiny 300 million-dollar
Convention Centre in the capital Kigali
epitomizes Kagame 's economic vision for
Rwanda he wants to transform the country
into the singapore of africa and some
economists now talk of the Rwandan
miracle
but exhales like former Prime Minister
Faust into Agora mangu who now lives in
Belgium claimed kogami's rule is based
on tyranny the expression on Appa for
the very few were of makita content
opposite at Raimondi you know who's
associate Academy was it Feeney in 2003
- agora mango challenge Kagame for the
presidency he was the only opposition
well the Marines unitary 0 vu 0 sis able
to tolerate what was in the official
result Kagame took 95% of the vote
- Agora mango is not alone in claiming
that Kagame z' presidential victories
have been rigged the move of our new nan
said to noon on twit
media ministry extraordinaire from
Vera's cylinder Shamwari some ecology
trans Philipp Lahm Politico Casilla Pro
is no members closed the positives
Rahman P is he - a menage to do a V
freedom ope hi besties there are
opposition parties but in reality Rwanda
is a one-party state and many opposed to
the government regularly complain of
harassment imprisonment and even murder
Kagame looks set to rule for some time
to come in 2015 his party ushered
through a constitutional change which
could in theory allow him to remain as
president until 2034 and while the 59
year old leader presides over a
seemingly peaceful country the West
seems content sometimes autocracy
works to deliver rapid reductions in
mass poverty sometimes democracy does
country is very different
one thing we've learned for sure is that
democracy is not the universal fix
foreign journalists can visit easily
enough but local media dare not
criticize the regime this ruler is to
have a clear secularism so conversely de
Bourgh and ET la democracy da
neutropenia
Kagame napur I still wanna London was a
party
Rwanda may be calm and orderly but if
this is based on fear then this is a
recipe neither for happiness prosperity
or durable peace